Have you ever seen Scotty Scheffler, the
golfer, talk about what happens when he
won the championship? That's one of the
few pattern breaks in somebody winning
>> I know exactly what you're talking I
made a video on it. I know I know
exactly what you're talking about.
>> [__] awesome. So, yeah, I mean, he
wins the
Masters or a Grand Slam, perhaps some
huge illustrious title, and he gets to
do the press juncture at the end. And
sitting down, and everyone's going,
"Dude,
how's this going to be? Like, how how
how does this feel?" And yeah, he
he has a slightly surprising response.
>> End of the day, it's like, "I'm not out
here to inspire the next generation of
golfers. I don't I'm not here to inspire
somebody else to be the best player in
the world, because what's the point? You
know, this is not a fulfilling
life. It's It's fulfilling from the
sense of accomplishment, but it's not
fulfilling from the sense of like the
deepest, you know,
places of your heart. You know, there's
a lot of people that make it to
what they thought was going to fulfill
them in life, and then you get there,
and then all of a sudden, you get to
number one in the world, and then
they're like, "What's the point?" And,
you know, I I really do believe that,
because, you know, what is the point?
>> Perhaps,
if you could be satisfied simply by
hitting the goal, you would kill
yourself.
>> That's the most most Jet Friends and
response to that video that I could ever
You you But you're not far off, right?
Like, the reason that the arrival
fallacy exists, and the reason that we
have hedonic adaptation, is that if the
first time you had sex, you were done
with sex for the rest of your life, or
the first time that you killed uh a
deer, you would be satisfied with that,
you wouldn't be chasing
>> Yeah.
>> the next piece of progress. Like,
>> there's this uh dukkha, d u k k
h a. Uh
it's this line from the Buddha, and a
lot of people here um uh
life is
unhappiness. Uh like, is one of the
translations of this, but Dukkha can
actually be translated as uh
unsatisfactoriness.
Uh, so it's not sorry, uh, life is
suffering. Like life is suffering is a
line from the Buddha, but it can also
Dukkha can also be translated as life is
unsatisfactoriness.
Like
>> Yeah.
>> Morgan Housel has this story about when
him and his family went away on holiday
and he'd been planning this trip for
ages and it was the first one that him
and his wife had got to do with the kids
and they they knew exactly where they
were going to sit at this resort. They
they they they'd looked at the menu in
advance. They knew what drinks they
wanted to get. They'd done everything.
And they arrived and they sat down the
first night and he thought about
what the experience was like and he's
like, "Well, the drink was nice, but
there was like a little bit too much ice
in and I probably should have got it
blended as opposed to as opposed to on
the rocks and like they were really
beautiful the table that we chose was
great, but like there was some sand
between my feet and that sort of was
irritating a bit and I I I look the veal
was lovely, but the salmon also could
have been a little bit better." And then
he walks out onto the balcony and he has
this thought like as they've arrived the
first day that they're there he's like,
"This is so great. We should come back
here next year." Like immediately in the
process of enjoying the thing he's
already moving the goalposts to the next
thing. The experience is unsatisfactory
and the
uh enjoyment of the thing is primarily
based around recreating the anticipation
of it again during the experience of it.
It's kind of deranged.
>> You know, I was I
a couple months ago
I went out to eat dinner and I ordered a
steak and they gave me a chicken and
I was happy
that they gave me the chicken because I
was like, "Wow, I was like expecting the
steak and I just got a chicken which is
like a curveball." And I started to
realize that this is like the ability my
my uh
my sophomore year AP US his- history
teacher always had this quote, "Roll
with the punches." You've probably heard
that before. Roll with the punches,
guys. Roll with the punches. But truly,
that's one of the best skills to develop
or personality traits. I don't know if
it's,
you know, genetic, but your ability to
just go with the flow is makes things so
much better.
My fam- I come from a very anxious
family. My family's very anxious. They
like to plan everything in advance, and
love them to death, but like sometimes
it's like, "Wow, like we're I feel like
like we're suffocating the experience.
And it's one of those things where it's
like if you just kind of let it happen,
then you're going to like it more.
>> Did you know your gut controls your
energy, your recovery, how well you
absorb everything that you eat, and the
one nutrient that keeps it all running
properly is fiber. Well, it turns out
that 95% of Americans don't get enough
of it, which is why I'm such a huge fan
of Momentous' Fiber Plus. Most fiber
supplements are one-trick pony, one type
of fiber solving one part of the
problem. Fiber Plus is a three-in-one
formula built to tackle digestion, gut
barrier strength, and blood sugar
stability all at once. I use this every
single day. It is kind of hard to get
enough fiber just through food alone,
and best of all, Momentous offers a
30-day money-back guarantee, so you can
buy it, try it every single day for 29
days, and if you don't love it, they
will just give you your money back.
Plus, they ship internationally. Right
now, you can get up to 35% off your
first subscription and that 30-day
money-back guarantee by going to the
link in the description below or heading
to livemomentous.com/modernwisdom
and using the code modernwisdom
at checkout. Congratulations, you made
it to the end of a clip, and the
full-length episode is available
right here.
Go on.